bon James d'accord
oui c'est niki lauda ça vient d'être
signé par ferrari c'est personne
qui quand il conduit comme un vieil homme en
ce moment n'est aucune incitation je le ferais je
conduis vite parce que je vous demande
c'est une bataille incroyable entre
ces deux grands  pilotes la
prochaine fois je t'aime plus de chance tu es
juste un fêtard c'est là que tout
le monde t'aime oui je sais je suis shérif non
tu n'es pas terrible non juste qui tu es
à ce stade de ta vie pour être un
champion il faut  plus que d'être
rapide, vous devez vraiment y croire
J'ai attendu ça toute ma vie Je
peux battre ce gars, croyez-moi, il est
un accusé cohérent, nous mettons sa vie en
jeu le jour où ils sont vraiment importants,
bienvenue dans la rancune de la course  correspondre à
une autre décennie
je me sens responsable de ce qui s'est passé
ils n'étaient pas confiants pour regarder vos
courses de fenêtres vous étiez également
responsable de me ramener dans la
voiture
d'une façon de vivre
seule façon de
conduire plus vous êtes proche de la mort plus
vous vous sentez vivant